john i
have to tell you the audiences are
watching i have never been a big fan
of um ufc mma even boxing like i watched
a few boxing rounds like i watched the
uh
i mean how many boxing fights have i
watched maybe the holyfield uh tyson
fight
you know where he got his ear bitten off
sort of thing that that's probably the
extent but
i like to participate in it personally
just as a
you know just from the approach of at
least being competent and having the
skills
plus the cardio drills are some of the
hardest you know you can do
in any profession i think anyway cardio
that comes along with fighting yeah
yeah um how did you get into fighting
like
how did you fall into so i i i you know
i'm 43 now so i grew up in the age
uh of you know pro wrestling you know
hulk hogan junkyard dog
and kind of vote call or whatever you
know i
eat those guys yeah because you were a
wrestler first right
yeah yeah i started wrestling in the
fourth grade but like i i started
getting into the
the you know pressing thing earlier and
then when i started to actually wrestle
in the fourth grade like i realized that
it was fake and i stopped watching pro
wrestling
um but like i also it was a time you
know when there was still plenty of
free boxing and ollie and stuff like
that on
on abc and wow world of sports things
like that howard cosell
so i watched a lot of boxing and stuff
when i was younger but my mom would
never let me get involved in boxing
i was able to get into wrestling because
i had
uh some some relatives and friends who
uh
friends of the family who were involved
and where i was going
and uh that kind of smooth things over
with that but yeah um
what was it like when you found out like
the wwf was fake was that like finding
out santa claus wasn't real
i had i cut the dicks off all my uh
little rubber wrestlers
i was so like this is shaky other actors
i was done with it like yeah it wasn't
like kind of upset i was like
i was betrayed it felt like i mean like
the weird thing is is that the
highest paid i think hollywood actor is
the rock and he got it you know
he got there by being a professor you
know an actor yeah and i don't have you
know i don't have any problem
with it but as a child it was to me it
was like devastating right i really
respected these guys they were tough
guys they were they were the best
fighters out there
and then it was all fake and then i was
kind of like you lied to me
so i've been a very skeptical person
about a lot of stuff my whole life
since then i think you um but i always
wanted to play
professional sports i thought football
was my going to be my thing yeah
so you know wrestling was an outlet that
i really enjoyed
uh that kept me in the weight room and
kept me active in the off season
for football so
it wasn't like my mindset to like
continue wrestling
you know down the road you know years
later still doing wrestling [ __ ]
like what did you want to be when you're
growing up did you want to be a fighter
or a wrestler
play football football okay i want to be
a professional athlete that was the
biggest thing was professional athlete
but football
it seemed like that was the easy way
easy way in for some reason
but like my senior year i wasn't big
enough wasn't fast enough
wasn't having anybody call uh you know
for me to play at a d1 school so i
decided i might as well go and wrestle
because i
loved wrestling and i thought you know
it was better to
walk onto a wrestling program and
that was d1 and and uh you know be a
letterman be a all-american
uh you know be national champion or i
could walk onto the
football team in a d1 school and maybe
play kickoff
my senior year and the competitive
competitive side of me wanted to
compete so i decided to go with
wrestling
and then how did you get into like
competitive fights where you got paid
for your time
that was uh the kind of accident as i
went to
purdue to wrestle my assist one of my
assistants was tom erickson and he was
currently fighting he was fighting over
japan tom was number
like two on the olympic ladder for
freestyle wrestling a heavyweight for
like 13 years under bruce bomb gardner
it's a huge man he's like 300 pounds 315
walking around
you know in decent shape and uh
he just brought guys around me who were
fighting like mark coleman and um
uh man ian freeman
those guys uh gary goodrich those guys
would come into town at purdue and work
with tom a little bit
so i would get some working with these
guys and i think it was
the combination of working with those
guys and listening to their stories
about life and how they were living and
like they're going to you know
stories about uh hookers and brazil
and mafia people in japan
and just the stories were just uh
seemed a lot of fun it seemed a lot more
fun than if i was a teacher in indiana
you know wrestling class so
that kind of got me interested in you
know listening to the money that they're
making and that was the time i started
putting more weight classes into the
sport
and by the time i got to my senior year
of wrestling
and uh at school i was you know doing
student teaching and with the student
teaching i was like this
this isn't for me i don't want to i
don't want to teach these people's
you know uh curriculums i don't want to
be told what to do
so i decided you know i'll do the fight
thing and
along with the fight thing you know i
can learn jiu jitsu and stuff and i get
enough
owning my own gym and then i don't have
to listen to somebody else's curriculum
or
[ __ ] so i follow the fight path with
the idea that you know i can
i can get around teaching at schools and
teaching my own school
you know in that path and then 2005 is
when ultimate fighter came on
on tv and and things just blew up
yeah did you did you see that coming
like did you see what dana white built
coming or was it just like a shock to
everybody that was
working no i knew it was gonna be big i
knew it was gonna be big
because i mean like wrestling was big
boxing was big nobody
really done anything like that with an
octagon and like you know you kind of do
whatever you want like
if you look back to history of prize
fighting
like mixed style fights have always been
around hundreds of years old
they they were able to um
corner a market and monopolize the
market and turn it into like oh we
repackaged this brand new thing
did a very good job at that but
the sport was already going on in brazil
it was big in japan
like there was you know if it's fighting
it's fighting it's a popular thing
so i always knew it was going to be on
somewhat level
big you know um
but i had no idea that it was going to
be eventually kind of monopolized the
way it has you know
when ufc around 2010 they ended up
buying
up all the other promotions all the top
talent all the top belts
they ended up sealing up 90 of the
market
in revenue and in uh
depth as far as fighters in each weight
class
and um again guys like i'm new to ufc
fighting it's not something that i
have watched much of i mean i've watched
some of john's fights you know prior to
this cast to kind of like catch up on it
all so i get a little bit of an idea
but what are the limitations when you're
in
like ufc or you know in the
octagon type of arena like is there
things that you can't do
is it wide open it's martial arts you um
it's very limited rule set so you can
you can fight on the ground there's
takedowns there's there's kicks
there's elbows there's knees uh once
you're on the ground though there's no
there's no knees to the head on the
ground um
there's a grounded opponent there's no
there's no soccer kick so if a guy's
down on the ground he can't kick him in
the head
there is a organization one fc that was
allowing that pride used to allow soccer
kicks i think
i think they should bring soccer kicks
in these head back
uh it just changes the game a little bit
more but um
yeah most strikings are allowed no
headbutts no groin strikes you're not
allowed to poke people in the eyes
or uh or small joint manipulations
aren't allowed
so get finger locks
hands are extremely gloved up you can't
do wrist locks but you're never going to
get one because
there's gloves and wraps all around the
wrist so it's usually
elbows and shoulders
you